our job in industry our job in security
we have
one job it's the same as military is to
protect
that's it nothing else there's no other
job we need to do is simply protect
people
but we don't do that we spend so much
time justifying our artificial
intelligence and it's better than
everybody else's
and there's 10 other companies waiting
outside your door to tell you that
they're better than the person before
them and it's
any company is just confused to all heck
by who we are what we are and what we're
doing
simplify the hell out of that to be
perfectly honest um so yeah
there'd be a few changes coming down the
line the um
so one of the things that um that i've
seen
um you know and talking to industry from
my perspective
is this idea and you brought it up
of um sanctuary
and um and so the the way that i
became more aware of
the problem was you know from a
briefing that was put together by one of
the top five audit firms that i
was able to look at where all the data
was sanitized but
in this briefing was a
was a number of vignettes of
targeted attacks you know they called
them
you know little c cyber economic i call
or big c cyber economic i call them
little c cyber
big e economic because the real attack
was economic cyber was an enabler
uh for the issue and um
so what what i what i came to understand
is
just exactly what you're saying these
companies have these problems they have
these attacks
and then they hide it and they hide it
for for a number of reasons
and i almost want to turn that on its
head and say
okay if we're going to if we're going to
create the sanctuary
um it ought to come with both carrots
and sticks in other words the carrots
are
if you uh if you fess up um we're going
to give you a tax
uh benefit some kind and a and a
and a um immunity benefit
but if you don't then we find out
you know you're going to get you're
going to get not only going to get
slammed in taxes
or penalties you're going to potentially
have
you know prosecutorial issues going on
and i think that would provide
kind of the the the openness and
transparency we have a thing in the
in in military aviation actually in in
in all aviation the united states called
a hazardous air traffic report
and so if you have a if you have a
traffic violation
in the air not not good it's not good at
a traffic violation in the air
but if you have one and as soon as you
land you as a pilot file a hatter
has us air traffic report then you're
basically given immunity and the whole
idea
is to promote aviation safety
you know so i i feel like that
your point is let's don't
you know let's create an environment
where
we are being as open and transparent as
we can about the problem
because the whole thing the whole idea
is to fix the problem
not to protect the company from being
sued not because ultimately
um and this is where i think the chinese
communist party has us over the barrel
they look at the entire system and says
we want to protect and say we want to
protect the system
and in our in our um in our society
each company is in essence their own
chinese communist party
and that's the only thing they care
about well and that's huge because again
think about i mean
you hit the nail on the head i land
anything i land a plane if there's an
issue
it's reported it's distributed the
plane's behind me the systems behind me
the architectures behind me
learn very very rapidly as to what's
going on
now we have the isakas and we have the
infra gods and everything else but just
the time it takes to go from point a to
point b
and dissemination of that intonation and
the intelligence behind it
it's just too slow it's way too slow so
as an adversary
i break into you using an attack vector
i don't have to change my tactics
because i know i can take out the next
10 15 companies because nobody's talking
to each other
and i also know again you know let's go
back to military stuff a perfect example
is
wouldn't it have been nice to have known
really early on that our
f-35 plans were not exactly in our hands
when we thought they were in our hands
wouldn't it be nice to have known to be
able to course correct to adjust to
understand
and all of the other criteria there
rather than finding out
an exponential amount of time later and
realizing that there's very little we
could have done about it
things like that are huge but again with
to your point it's it's we are you know
i
this country is amazing and it's been
very very nice to me but it's a cluster
of 50 little countries inside one
country
and it's like good grief you we're all
batting for the same freaking team
let's try to all work more effectively
[Music]
together
you